[Applause]
today we are going to talk about South
Korea or as Kim Jong and we would call
this of the bath career you've probably
heard of this country because it's
probably where your mobile phone your TV
screen or possibly even your car with
manufactured or perhaps because it's the
place where the most-watched YouTube
video of all time came from one condom
star yes South Korea is a big power not
only at the cultural level but also at
an economic one I'm sure every one of
you watching this video have at least
one product from Samsung Hyundai or LG
around you South Korean companies are
absolutely on fire and this is a
surprise given that in the 1960s South
Korea was an extremely poor country and
no we're not talking about relative
poverty or other countries like Gabon or
Zimbabwe were actually more developed at
this time nonetheless in just one
generation South Koreans went from
starvation for one of the most
prosperous societies in the world and so
now comes the big question what exactly
did South Korea do to becomes quite so
rich and hold on a second because if
you're a regular viewer I probably know
what you're thinking you're thinking oh
it's another video where visual politics
tell me how marvelously wealthier
country became because of free-market
capitalism right right well I'm sorry to
disappoint you more North to part of the
story of South Korea it's a bit
different
[Music]
a source compared with their neighbors
to the north South Korea is a free
paradise but their economic model has
one peculiarities that sets it apart
from the rest of the world so then the
question is what are the reasons that
explained this incredible progress in
South Korea and more importantly why was
Gangnam style so controversial in South
Korea both of these questions I promise
they are actually related and these are
the questions that we're going to answer
in today's video from the top to the
bottom as you probably know in 1953 the
Korean Peninsula was it into two halves
after a war which killed over 2 million
people at that moment we can actually
say that South Korea was the country
that was actually in more trouble
economically the North had all of the
industries and companies while the South
was agricultural and underdeveloped
schools had no desks and most of the
children got the majority of their
nutrition from powdered milk that was
given by the US and Europe this is why
in 1960 after many protests General Park
chung-hee organized a coup d'etat and
took power this is how the first South
Korean dictatorship started during the
following 27 years the country had three
different dictators all of them came
into power in a violent way by
overthrowing the previous one
nevertheless despite the political
instability in those times
the South Korean model in Korea
that's all a minute because this economy
is not as free and your mic in fact a
free market is organized in a bottom-up
fashion the private businesses decide
how when and what they want to sell then
the state comes in and regulates all of
that activity through various laws
well park jurong east system was quite
the opposite this was a top-down system
his policy was the meet with the most
important families in the country who
controlled most of South Korea's
industries this group included the
founders of Samsung and LG
so essentially he put them in a room and
said look from now on I will give you
whatever you need to grow if one year
you cannot weigh your taxes it's ok I'll
forgive you you need some grants well
bingo you can have it you need to borrow
some money from abroad well the
government is going to back your loan
even if you can't pay your debts the
state is going to help you we are weak
our country will be in jeopardy in order
for a country not to fall it must
cultivate its own strengths nonetheless
unlike other countries like France South
Korea didn't put up any barriers to
international trade actually since that
very first moment the government
guaranteed rule of law and low taxes for
all businesses regardless of where they
came from but not only that Park
chung-hee gave all kinds of tax
incentives the companies and individuals
to invest and save money
[Music]
in other words the big conglomerates
like hi MJ or Lotte got to compete in an
open market with other corporate
juggernauts from Japan or the United
States but at the same time they also
have help from the government since
South Korea has no natural resources but
a big population those companies put a
focus on industries that required a
large workforce that's manufacturing and
this this was the beginning of the
Tribal Nation imagine the life of one of
the hundred thousand workers employed by
Samsung in South Korea he gets up in the
morning in a house built by CYT he
construction company run by the Samsung
Group when he's breakfast he watches the
latest visual politic video so we like
to think on his samsung galaxy stone
then he takes his Renault Samsung car
yup you read that right Renault cars are
manufactured by Samsung in South Korea
and guess where he has his car insurance
yep you're getting the trends here you
get different Samsung then after a hard
day working it yeah okay you're getting
the picture now now while South Korean
man he wants to go get some beers with
his colleagues so he goes to Cantina yes
again you're getting the picture and the
weekend comes and our friend wants to
spend some quality time with his wife
and children so he decides to take them
to a park so where do you think it'd go
yep he goes to something's very own
Disney style theme park in other words
if you work for Samsung the company is
everything
we're talking about the biggest cable in
all of South Korea and now you might be
wondering what exactly is a chi ball
tribals are big conglomerates supported
by the state some of them like two
already defunct Daewoo
we're started by the administration
itself others like Hyundai were born in
the 1940s
most of them started being family-owned
but as they grew they became public
companies and all of them have a number
of different business lines and products
for example LG is famous for their TVs
and their mobile phones but in South
Korea they also the distributors of
coca-cola in total there are around 100
tribals and they are the biggest asset
in the South Korean economy now as I
said before the government the size of
red carpet under their feet but this
doesn't mean they have a blank check
this is why when a chi ball as big as
day we went bankrupt no one came to bail
them out this is a clear incentive for
these companies to be on the edge of
innovation for instance in 2008 Sony the
Japanese firm wanted to create the first
OLED TVs but this technology there
wasn't advanced enough and the screens
were pretty expensive even priced too
high the most of the luxury market so
the Sony guys put the project on hold
and they never really got back onto it
South Korea and LG have the same
technology now they have the same
problem so well what did they do
well they launched OLED mobile folks
with a much smaller display this way
they took advantage of their assets and
what is more important if they learn how
to work with this new technology this is
why in a very short amount of time they
found ways to produce affordable OLED TV
screen now hold on for just a minute
because there's another more important
part which helps explain to this very
innovative sculpture
south korean education will nerd South
Korean children have always had one of
the best marks in the international Pisa
test the whole country stops during
university entrance exams and South
Korean schools spend whatever they need
to guarantee the best education for
their boys and girls now the flip side
of this coin is that those kids have the
biggest suicide rate in the world in
fact all of South Korea has a problem
with suicides the country having the
second highest suicide rate per capita
in the world since the beginning the
government is understood that chi bowls
would need high-skilled workers
so they designed an educational system
that works in line with the nation's
companies this explains why South Korean
children are incredibly good at maths
and of excellence memorization abilities
further their respect for authority and
hierarchy it's almost religious and this
is why none of them want to start a
company
the dream of every South Korean is to
wind up working in one of these Chi box
if they work hard they might even become
a manager and get a house in their
paradise on earth that is a famous
district of Seoul with a name that's
going to sound pretty familiar to you
yep I'm talking about the Gangnam
district that's the meaning of Gangnam
style gotcha
copy honey a human and warm girl during
the day a classy one someone who knows
how to enjoy the freedom of a cup of
coffee but when the night comes down her
heart gets warmer because she is a girl
with two faces hey sexy lady your big
brother
Gangnam style this is an extract from
that famous song that became so popular
back in 2012 even led to their main
singer psy getting into some trouble
with the authorities uses and lyrics
having inappropriate content for a
society that's obsessed with respect for
authority size aesthetics are something
as radical as the hip movements from
Elvis back in the nineteen fifties the
truth is that a hierarchical economy one
which relies on a few big corporations
is not a good recipe for a stable
economy in fact South Korea big as it is
in the manufacturing industry lagged
behind in other fields such as services
or finance
[Music]
since the economy depends so much on
governmental and cabal decisions there
is always no space for entrepreneurs
think about it I mean even if you wanted
to start a company is pretty hard to
compete when your competitors are
supported by big government but not only
that these hierarchical structures are
not as efficient as you might think
in fact most of the Chi boards have
become bureaucratic VMs that require
lots and lots of money to work this firm
leaves the sales of mobile phones in the
entire world however they make almost no
profit and that is a problem
[Applause]
anyway things are starting to change a
lot of South Korean youngsters have been
educated in Europe or America and now
they are coming back to their country of
origin with a new and more critical
mindset and a more entrepreneurial
spirits this generation is creating the
reefer startup in ecosystems but there
is still a lot of work to be done
[Music]
anyway whether you like it or not we
must admit that this top-down model has
been successful in South Korea let's
decide all of this there are still some
questions that must be answered what
would happen if a country like Samsung
collapsed what would happen in the
country as a whole and not only that but
this marriage between politics and
business has created lots of incentives
for corruption on a massive scale
but that's something we're going to
cover in a future video in the meantime
you should absolutely check out this
other video we made about the rising
Asian middle class and also do not
forget to check our reach into the media
podcast where you can hear the voice
that is in my voice on this video and
now the question is do you think that
this crossover between hierarchy and the
free market could ever work in other
countries and what's your opinion about
the South Korean system please do leave
your opinion in the comment section
below we'd love to hear from you and do
not forget that we upload brand new
videos every Monday and Thursday so
don't forget to subscribe so you
wouldn't miss anything and if you like
this video please do give us a thumbs up
and as always I'll see you in the next
video and if you'd like to hear more of
my lovely voice you can join us at
reconsider the podcast that covers
politics but we don't do the thinking
for you available on your favorite
podcast see you there
you